Honorable member Fonkana.
Madam Speaker,
I need your guidance.
There are three issues that I raised.
I don't know if I can ask three questions
in relation to those three issues
or the honourable member. Actually,
I think we overstretch ourselves
when we ask the honourable minister
to ask er to address three matters.
It should have been only one issue.
So in accordance with our Standing Order 1,
34, 4, which reads,
for the avoidance of doubt,
where more than one matter of agent
public importance is admitted
and the presiding officer
considered that each matter justifies debate,
the presiding officer shall give priority to the matter
which in the presiding officer's opinion
is the most agent and important.
So the honourable member for Khan Khana
will ask one question relating to one subject only.
Then the other members can cover,
you can lure us with your,
the other honourable members to cover each other.
You don't have to ask similar questions.
Madam Speaker,
in a letter written by the Permanent Sector
in the Ministry of agriculture dated 22 January 2024,
Madam Yvonne S.
Impondu to the Commissioner General,
Zambia Revenue Authority.
Do you have that letter with you?
I'm reading it.
Is it, is it er original.
It is, Madam Speaker.
Let me have a look.
What are you,
you will,
you will. Actually,
the letter is supposed to be
handed over to the clocks at the table,
not to me. And we have ashes in the house,
Madam Speaker,
in this letter,
it's referenced submission obsession.
The letter that you have brought is a photo copy.
Do you, is it certified?
Is it certified,
Madam Speaker?
It is stamped.
It's printed from the phone.
So, no, no, no,
no. That's not sufficient.
Stop the clock.
Let's, you know, these things, we are guided by the,
our very onstanding orders. Yeah.
1:41, honourable members,
for tabling of documents by back benches.
This is addressed in Standing Order 1,
41, admissibility rules for tabling private documents.
Well, this must be a public document.
So we'll look at 140,
Standing Order 140. Tabling of private documents by,
sorry, public. 1:39.
1:39 tabling of public documents by buck Bencher.
1. A buck bencher may table a public,
public document
provided it is in an original,
it is an original document.
2, a backbencher shall not stable
a copy of a public document
unless the copy has been certified as a true copy
of the original
document by the relevant head of government, ministry,
department or agency
that has custard you of the original document.
That is what the Standing Orders is saying.
It's not me.
You are accordingly guided.
Please do not refer to that document.
It's not proper before the house.
Madam Speaker,
my question to the minister of agriculture.
Honourable minister,
you are aware that zetanes as a depot in kasumbalesa
where they are stocking and selling Millimil
Lebod Ego milling,
which millimil is coming from South Africa.
That means G M o millimil coming from s a
is being sought in the Z N s depot in kasumbalisa.
Would you then confirm now that the Zambian government
through Z N s is importing GM
or millimil and selling it to the Congolese
or whether they are Congolese or otherwise in Zambia
at kommensa in Kasumbalessa?
I thank you,
Madam Speaker.
The honorable minister of agriculture.
Thank you, Madam Speaker.
Sorry,
Madam Speaker.
Thank you, Madam Speaker.
I am aware and it is true that zedernis is a floating
Maze Mid mill at Kasumba Resso for sale to the d
mostly for the d R C market.
I'll, I'll explain.
Madam Speaker,
I want to repeat, I am aware,
I am aware that Z N s
is a flaweding Miramil at Kasumba lesser.
The Miramil
Madam speaker
is deliberately put at Kasumba Resso to protect
Zambians from the Congolese
would come and buy our minimum.
It is a wonder,
Madam Speaker,
I wonder that a leader
who understands exactly what the government is doing
would come and stand in the house here
and challenge a very noble cause
which is meant to protect,
which is meant to protect our consumers.
Yes, Madam Speaker,
I agree. Z N s is serving members.
Can we have some order?
Yes, Madam Speaker.
Z N s is serving minimum.
But I cannot stand here and say they are setting G m
O minimum. No,
but they are setting minimum.
That is true.
If you have Got proof that it is G. M. O.
Come and prove it here.
Oh, the honorable members, can you please take your seats?
May the minister continue? Thank you.
Let me take this opportunity
to inform the nation that the country,
the government is so concerned about these citizens
or the honourable members.
Please, can we allow the minister to finish?
Let me talk.
You want a, you have us a question.
Let me answer.
I am extremely happy,
Madam Speaker,
that the government,
the current government is so
concerned of the warfare of the citizens in Zambia
that instead of allowing foreigners to come and
consume our minimum,
we have put millimil in strategic places
so that the foreign nationals can buy that millimil
and go back without coming deep into our country.
And Madam Speaker,
that is the way a country that is concerned
for its citizens should behave.
It is important,
Madam Speaker,
especially honourable members from the Copper Belt,
to appreciate that the government was going to order
honourable members,
order, order
honourable members
if we proceeded this rate. Are we,
you are inviting me to employ Standing Order 2, 0, 8.
So as you conduct yourself in what,
whatever manner, be aware,
maybe you might browse through Standing Order 2, 0, 8.
Now, may the owner,
let me conclude,
Madam Speaker,
that what we are doing in Kasumbalessa,
we are also going to do at tsunami border.
We are also going to
Do at any border where we see an influx
of nationals from other countries to come into Zambia.
And we are proud of what we are doing.
Madam Speaker, thank you.